le consommateur qui achète de la viande
déjà impacté fait souvent son choix en
fonction de la fraîcheur apparent du
produit où il se fit à la date
d'emballage inscrits sur le paquet or
notre enquête en caméra cachée et les
témoignages de plusieurs bouchers révèle
que la viande n'est pas toujours aussi
fraîche qu'on veut nous le faire croire
nous avons fait analyser quelques
morceaux de viande en laboratoire les
résultats sont troublants ce boucher qui
a demandé que l'on protège son anonymat
travail chez iga il a accepté de lever
le voile sur une pratique qu'ils
contestent depuis longtemps il ya une
technique qui vous dérange profondément
qui est utilisé dans votre métier
qu'elle est elle leur est un bel âge en
théorie les viande emballée en magasins
doivent être consommés dans un délai de
deux à trois jours après la date
d'emballage selon la recommandation du
ministère de l'agriculture des pêcheries
et de l'alimentation du québec le mapaq
mais oui j'ai un travail notre
collaborateur on aurait tort de se fier
à cette date pour savoir si le produit
est encore comestibles chaque matin
avant l'ouverture du magasin on retire
la viande des tablettes
le produit est périmé qui les rend au
chat roux en jour on vérifie si des
bonds au jeu et à loder on leur ait un
balcon leurs mains sur les tablettes le
problème c'est qu'au passage les
bouchers appose une date plus récentes
sur l'étiquette tout ce qui est beau on
les tire de combien de jours dans notre
région les tirs d'une journée
dépendamment des magasins et
dépendamment des gérants on peut lui
donner un autre trois jours modifier la
date d'emballage même d'une seule
journée c'est illégal selon la loi
fédérale sur les aliments et les drogues
ces dates doivent nécessairement
correspondre au jour où le produit a été
emballé pour la première fois cet autre
boucher qui veut garder l'anonymat
puisqu'il est toujours à l'emploi de 1 g
a expliqué que les clients courent des
risques s'ils ne connaissent pas la
vraie date d'emballage moi je peux
décider d'un faire un petit poulet en
fin de semaine et décidé de l'acheter
aujourd'hui la personne qui l'a acheté
aujourd'hui qu'ils pensent qu'il est
d'aujourd'hui en réalité il n'est pas
d'aujourd'hui il est devenu deux jours
faites le et faites cuire son poulet en
fin de semaine ça fait cinq jours là il
va être malade un poulet c'est dangereux
après cinq jours selon plusieurs sources
dont ce troisième boucher qui témoigne
lui aussi sous le couvert de l'anonymat
trafic et la date d'emballage n'est pas
une pratique exclusive à iga à ma
connaissance tout le monde le fait dans
tout où tous les magasins que j'ai fait
dans ma vie ils le font tous nous avons
décidé de munir un nos collaborateurs
d'une caméra cachée pendant qu'il
travaille à la boucherie dirigé à nous
avons changé les voies et masquer tous
détails qui permettraient d'identifier
le 5 novembre lamballe eux explique que
chaque matin il faut retirer les paquets
qui date de deux ou trois jours pour
leur donner une nouvelle ville ce
matin-là ortir d à l'âge les produits
daté du 2 novembre
l'équipe ouvre les emballages les sens
et détermine si le produit peut être ré
emballé de nouveau ou s'il doit être
jetée puis les paquets qui passent le
test sont déposés sur le chariot voici
une reconstitution de la conversation
entre lamballe euse et notre
collaborateur chou ça sent pas bon
auront congé il parle ensuite des
produits daté du 2 novembre les produits
qui arrivent sur la palette c'est pour
changer la date j'enlève le 2 oui un bal
en date du 3 novembre
jour là on a donc donné un jour de plus
un produit qui risque d'être périmés
mais jusqu'à quel point pour le savoir
nous avons acheté certains de ses
morceaux de viande pour les faire
analyser nous avions sélectionné des
paquets portant 1,8 sur le poulet ou un
site sur le steak d'une information
utiliser l interne par certains
supermarchés pour préciser que le
produit a été ré emballé à 8 ou 7 heures
le matin
puis nous avons transporté nos
échantillons à température contrôlée
vers un laboratoire reconnu qui les a
analysés selon les critères du mapaq
trois micro organismes ont été testés si
l'un des trois étaient présents à plus
de 1 millions de bactéries par g de
viande l'échantillon seraient jugées
impropres à la consommation
les deux steaks était acceptable par
contre un des morceaux de poulet
contenait trois millions 900 mille
bactéries par g l'autre 35 millions
est-ce que vous mangeriez secours et là
je ne mangerai pas du poulet qui
contient 35 millions de bactéries ça
c'est certain monique lacroix est
renversé par ses résultats
c'est inacceptable à cause de la
fraîcheur du produit et le risque de
présence de bactéries pathogènes
de bactéries qui vont produire des
toxines si jamais il ya une bactérie qui
produit une toxine qui présente bien
l'oeil risque de toxi-infections
alimentaires parce que la toxine devons
résister à la cuisson le mapaq déplore
que certains marchands phase dure
étiquetage illégal mais explique que la
manoeuvre est difficile à dépister les
inspecteurs vérifient les aspects qui
sont vérifiables
avec les informations dont nous
disposons ce n'est pas nécessairement
une situation qui est facile à observer
parce que forcément ça ne se fait pas
nécessairement dans des heures où
l'inspection se fait chez sobeys
propriétaire de la bannière iga au
québec on n'a pas voulu commenter les
résultats des analyses de laboratoire
sobeys fait valoir qu'elle a recours aux
services d'une compagnie privée pour
inspecter ses établissements en plus se
soumettre aux inspections du mapaq quoi
qu'il en soit la compagnie condamne
cette pratique c'est quelque chose qu'on
approuve pour ce quelque chose qu'on ne
supporte pas ça reste quand même un acte
isolé parce que ce n'est pas du tout
dans les procédures et dans la politique
l entreprise
prendre auprès de ses marges
pourtant au cours des deux dernières
années 2g à différents de ceux où nous
avons enquêté on était prêt à changer
des dates emballages selon des documents
obtenus en vertu de la loi d'accès à
l'information
l'origine de coteau-du-lac avait changé
la date d'emballage de pépites de saumon
fumé un incident son propriétaire
attribue à un imbroglio avec le mapaq
celui de saint-hyacinthe avait modifié
la date d'emballage de sacs de moules et
de filets de truite saumonée le
propriétaire dit que c'était par mégarde
tous deux ont été condamnés à 500
dollars d'amendé par le mapaq quoi qu'il
en soit dès que nous avons contactés
sont obèses la compagnie a rappelé à
l'ordre l'ensemble de son personnel une
note de service sur laquelle nous avons
mis la main a été envoyé dans les 285
épiceries iga du québec adressé à tous
les employés la note rappelle que les
produire et emballé doivent afficher la
date d'emballage original